[Aplausos]
[Música]
como é desistir de quem você é
isso não significaria a morte ou a
própria morte
quantas vezes nós morremos no mês tailan
lutas frança
kayla antes de tirar a própria vida
ela deixou esta reflexão essa mensagem
para nós
thaila não binária trans negra ativista
tinha sonhos tinha desejos almejava
viver tinha vida porém cai lá não
suportou a dor não suportou o olhar do
outro
indiretamente eu prometia kayla que
aonde eu tiver fala onde eu estiver eu
iria trazer caiu comigo
caio apresente a cara talvez não está
aqui fisicamente mas eu sinto que eu
espero que vocês sintam thaila lucas
frança sentimento de não pertencimento
é um sentimento que dylan fera que
corrói machuca dói sentir-se não
pertencente é literalmente a adoecer e
dor
como é por exemplo se constituir viver
em um mundo em uma realidade no qual
você não se enxerga
você não se vê representado seja nos
livros na mídia você não se vê como que
é viver num mundo num contexto numa
realidade no qual você grita você fala
mas como é por exemplo sobreviver e aqui
eu não estou falando de viver novamente
como é sobreviver em um mundo ou em uma
realidade como essa existe uma foca uma
famosa frase que as pessoas gostam muito
e eu particularmente também gosta que é
eu me faço a partir do olhar do outro ou
eu me constitua partir do olhar do outro
mas de outra este que não escuta que não
enxerga que não visualiza que outro é
este
como falar de amor como falar de
auto-cuidado numa realidade que muitas
vezes aniquila e termina apaga e
invisibilizar algumas realidades
felizmente felizmente é possível
transformar ressignifica e é possível a
gente literalmente passar da dor do luto
para a luta
ou seja viver hoje eu estou aqui talvez
eu sou um vencedor
desde cedo eu tive que lidar com a morte
precoce mente eu tive que
entender porque os meus entes queridos
porque meu irmão porque que meus avós
morriam morreram e petiz meus amigos
morriam não foi fácil uma criança um
adolescente que também assim como cá ela
almejava viver almejava sonhar mas todos
que teoricamente eu amava estava
morrendo sumindo saindo e foi nesse
sentimento de não pertencimento e desse
sentimento de que está acontecendo que
eu vi a morte como uma possibilidade
como uma saída
afinal assim como cá ela gritava falava
chorava hesperia vá mas poucas pessoas
escutavam poucas pessoas olhavam o que
fazer
pensei na morte e isso é muito triste
porque nós trabalhamos com a idéia de
que o filme faça a partir do olhar do
outro que outra este como estamos
olhando enxergando visualizando essa
outra realidade
e aqui e gostaria de começar a refletir
com vocês
justamente uma ideia de que uma autora
trabalha e muito bem
judith butler ela trabalha a noção de
que algumas vidas são literalmente
construídas para serem importadas para
serem amadas olhados cuidadas amparados
afetadas como vidas e até mesmo em
lotadas mas a vida no qual a gente
literalmente
descarto joga fora sequer olha sequer
visualiza sequer enxerga ou se quer
escuta que vida com essas talvez por
exemplo pessoas em situação de rua
negros negras população lgbt e população
indígena mulheres que mulheres ea gente
vai pensar em várias vidas que
infelizmente não são construídas para
serem importadas e aqui entra uma
questão que é de suma importância de
suma importância e pensarmos e
refletirmos sobre como estamos
construindo a nossa sociedade de que
modo estamos construindo as nossas
relações
de que modo estamos construindo a minha
visão a sua visão entre uma questão
muito importante porque a gente sabe e
eu tenho a premissa na verdade de que se
algo na minha frente é um problema ou se
uma realidade é um problema o seu objeto
é um problema
eu vou lá resolvi interviú enfim tenta
modificar por exemplo quantos aqui já
pensaram na acessibilidade deste local
de uma pessoa cadeirante por uma pessoa
deficiente física não é um problema é
outra realidade é que eu vou pensar que
eu vou olhar pra que eu vou sentir me
atingir
agora se eu visualizo essa realidade
enquanto um problema eu vou entender
venho cuido resolvo isso nesse problema
mas esse processo ele não é feito ou ter
pelo menos eu tenho a premissa de que
não é feito na solitude
nós precisamos literalmente na e pela
coletividade possibilitar
mudanças e possibilitar que as pessoas
minimamente possam escutar e enxergar e
transformar essas outras realidades
a gente sabe que falar sobre suicídio
não é fácil falar sobre morte não é
fácil
eu costumo brincar com os meus alunos
quando a gente entra nestas temáticas
relacionadas à morte ou suicídio quem
aqui pensa na cor do seu caixão quem é
que pensa no seu velório agente nega a
gente literalmente deixa debaixo do
tapete
e entre uma questão muito importante
porque trabalhar com o suicídio já é um
tabu e pensar por exemplo suicídio ou a
morte de pessoas negras lgbt store assim
mais ainda um tabu
por isso que eu intitulei essa fala por
sabemos aonde dói eu sei onde me doía
eu imagino e sinto aonde a carla sentia
as dores mas poucas pessoas conseguem
enxergar e aí nós questionamos
será que de fato eu cá ela e outras
pessoas existem aliás vocês me escutam
vocês escutam como que a gente aprende a
escutar o outro como que eu escuto o
outro pararam pra pensar uma questão
simples que a gente vai naturalizando a
nossa escuta a nossa visão e aí muitas
vezes a nossa visão lasmar
eu não consigo enxergar e visualizar o
outro outro quem sabe a mim mesmo e aqui
infelizmente nessa tentativa de tornar a
borda do invisível visível eu escrevi um
livro tentei trabalhar vida adoecimento
e suicídio
tentei entender o que a psicologia o que
a ciência falava sobre o suicídio de
jovens negros lgbts sabe que eu
encontrei foi o silêncio
não temos nenhum material então se eu
não enxergo que é um problema como eu
vou intervir como eu vou olhar a cuidar
amparar
portanto eu proponho que nesta noite ou
nesta fala nesta escuta nós possamos
entender e começar a refletir e começar
de fato não só reconhecer a apreender
mas agir não mais na sua atitude mas em
coletividade para tentar mínima mente
enxergar visualizar e nomear porque nós
estamos repetindo os erros do passado e
por que não aprendemos com a história a
história como vimos não é linear
a história processo porque estamos
repetindo os erros do passado
é muito triste eu não sei se vocês têm a
dimensão e não sei se vocês me escutam
mas é muito triste pessoas tentarem o
suicídio ou usarem do seu próprio corpo
para se comunicarem para dizerem ei ei
ei eu não estou bem e aí construímos um
mito de que quem está tentando suicídio
está chamando a atenção de fato está
chamando a atenção de atenção olhe
escute
precisamos falar mais sobre de que modo
estamos falando de que modo estamos
escutando de que modo estamos
visualizando este fenômeno que atravesse
perpassa todo
doze todas eu gosto muito de uma altura
é o roots feminista negra e ela fala que
chegou a teoria porque ela estava
sofrendo ela estava literalmente
angustiada della sera da paulo victor
chegou a teoria porque ele estava
dilacerado não via perspectiva
eu só vi a morte tentei sobrevive
foi a partir da teoria a partir da
psicologia a partir da possibilidade da
fala que eu vi e vislumbrei a vida mas
eu não consegui isso na solitude
eu tive pessoas que escutaram que me
visualizar o que puderam enxergar até
quando continuaremos perdendo tá elas e
dentre outras pessoas então é difícil
talvez possa ser deprimente escutar mas
é de suma importância
pensarmos se nós queremos construir uma
sociedade compromissada ética política
social plural nós devemos todos lutarmos
para que isso aconteça
se nós continuaremos perdendo vidas
perdendo os sonhos perdendo desejos e
essa luta ela não é uma luta sozinha
e aqui cabe uma outra proposta que eu
faço pra vocês talvez cabe nós damos um
passo para trás olharmos a história
reaprendermos com a história
escutar mais do que falar do que
desligar do que carimbar um destino
final para essas pessoas
portanto trago comigo
kayla conceição evaristo no qual ela
afirma
eles combinaram de nos matar mas a gente
combinamos de não morrer
e assim eu no meio a história que me foi
apagada a história que tentou me
silenciar
ea história que tentou e que tentará
ainda me a pagar mas não irá porque não
estou só a vida negra se importam e das
negras lgbts importam resistem existem e
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]